d'c mets un plan sur les les le truc
pour empêcher que le SAL se barre tu
vois là tu peux zoomer là-dedans tu vois
voilà
voilà jeolis avec les deux couleurs
là le point y est ERC je trouve pas moi
moi non
plus
arrêteend est le rater il
est un
problème
mer
ok
coup0 imag avec le plan d'avant plan
large 60 im second l'impression que
c'est un peu flou mais c'est
[Musique]
comm
vous
voulez ça concne 30
[Musique]
secondes
carrément Fran qui nous fait le grand
jeu
là
gauche à droite à droite pour
l'image c'est bien fait un bon bonne
transition
de qui
regarde regarde celu-l regardeu il r
tout seul regarde ah ouais génial
regarde regarde je le ressors qu' se
retourne regarde toi ah d'accord et là
je le manipule regarde attention je
faire sortir regarde
ouis je le dirige
je t'en pris ça
[Musique]
tourne
là il y en a une en bas mais je vois pas
trop où il es
ouais tu es dessus je
crois juste à gauche du C là je crois
mais je suis pas sûr
non c'est pas
[Musique]
une
pardon un touttit peu à
droite c'est
bon voilà voilà c'est bon
[Musique]
ok
plusque blanche c'est
[Musique]
plus à
droite
voilà faire en vertical pour voir ça
don un
peuu pour tester le
[Musique]
trucess ver s'il
plaît
[Musique]
du
j'aime bien se des trucsous il rien mais
j'aime bien ces
[Musique]
pl
la lumière plus sympa
[Musique]
déjoite
pardon ah
ou plus
joliess de fmer unu ta droite pour voir
un pe
peu VO
trop c'est bien comme ça devant on AR
sur du blanc du rouge c'est
[Musique]
bien c'est un
peu le blanc c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon
ça c'est
bien
plus en plus
l'impression
allez ça
t
[Musique]
alle s te
PLT
[Musique]
à droite sur le bien
une
dans
[Musique]
ou pas qu'É il seront il seront double
ok alle
coupourci
[Musique]
Dr
voilà voilà voilà c'est bien
[Musique]
ça dessous c'est joli
d'ailleurs no regarde truc noir qui
droite c'est marrant ça de Roch noir ça
je pense c'est bien
[Musique]
ossible pas
St on a combien de là euh 26 minutes
on est tout prê
[Musique]
ok attends il y en a encore un qui
arrive un très beau car voilà je te dir
quand il en aura plus voil et après tu
vas tomber dans un grand truc blanc là
et là tu vas pouvoir arrêter tu V tomber
dedans bien à droite bien à droite VO
est est voilà
voilà par que c'est un peu trop
ver
plus tu veux
[Musique]
allezvers
grand qu'on voit
en
bien de vague regarde
bien il y a du
[Musique]
blanc ton copain Christian il fait
beaucoup de euh
TR il y a moins de il a moins de blanc
là il
les blanch en face ça va être super
beau de vitesse
jeond comme n tu asimpression c'est le
blanc c'est super beau ça super joli
ça du coup ça va être super
l fa un pequer un peuêre un petit peu VO
ça donne tu peux piquer d'ici
[Musique]
par
ATT
mag
les
vill il est à droite
devite pied du
blanc
mon mon
mon descende un petit peu qu'on un
peu pas loin des
très à fil de travers en arrivant je
pense avec le
noir dégage un peu vers la
gauche un peu les
blanch dans sens du soleil faire d'ici
pas pass en travers on a plus côté
magique reste 3
minutes
ah allez coup c'est sûr